all right the patriots and the ravens
from sunday night football 2317 victory
you watched the film why weren't the
ravens able to run the ball like we
thought they would well i think the
first thing is all right the first thing
i wrote more than anything all right is
just this that i thought one the fact
that the patriots played the 49ers a few
weeks ago with all the movement and
things they do in the run game there are
some similarities there with the ravens
and how they attack the edge of a
defense i think that experience helped
help new england in this football game i
do hey the weather
of course was an issue the biggest thing
i will look at more than anything is
number 93 lawrence guy being back
healthy and the interior part of their
defensive line for the patriots where
we've talked about you know they don't
have a lot of big people in the last two
weeks they were missing him to have him
back it changes their football team but
they were all over some of these ravens
run concepts and it went back to the old
thing again mike to where yeah they
crossed chaos and and belichick did a
great job and then it came back into oh
it's a rainy night and we don't think
your past game's that great
and that allowed new england to put more
eggs into the stopping the run basket
mike they played three deep four under
almost the whole game
as far as coverages with just a little
man sprinkled in there they were all
over what they needed to do just to stop
the run game but because the pass game
is so predictable in baltimore two they
weren't threatened by it so they could
play simple coverages and go hey we know
they kind of attack here and there and
this is what they do and that played in
their favor
and and and look this is one of the big
flaws it is this ravens team you will
come up against somebody who stops what
you want to do can you do the other
thing
and sometimes they just physically can't
stop what you want to do sometimes they
can we didn't think the patriots would
be able to stop it but when you can't
take away the run they force you to
pivot to something else where you
struggle and especially given the way
the weather was on sunday night yeah a
little more reason for the ravens pass
game to struggle and it worked out well
you know you wonder if if the conditions
had been perfect
is that the way the game would have gone
i really do think you know usually
that's a little bit of rain no there
were times
like monsoon conditions you're right i
know i i'm i'm on the camp of
the the monsoon conditions hurt the
baltimore ravens in this football game
they're the team that has a little bit
more of the explosive element on the
football field of course with lamar and
then hollywood brown and duvernay
they're the ones that have shown to be
able to make those big time type of
plays and things like that jk davis and
everything it was slow track and then it
even hampered their pass game even more
to where
you know hey
new england at times when they're
playing those three deep looks the
safety the middle safety who's supposed
to be 15 20 yards deep he was 9 and 10
yards deep one because yeah i'm sure
they had good feel for what the ravens
and how they were going to attack them
but two i bet you bill told them hey
come up a little bit you know i don't
think 30 and 40 yard posts are going to
be part of the game plan this week and
that played into their favor as well as
far as new england's concerned
flip it over to the new england offense
why do you think they were able to have
uh the kind of success they did against
a pretty good ravens defense i mean i i
didn't i i thought the patriots would be
able to run the football but not to the
extent in which they we saw on sunday
night i mean it just it's it's the most
well-coached detailed
power old-school running football game
in football i'm not saying it's the most
creative i'm still going to give
shanahan the the the gold medals that's
concerned but the patriots
it's like watching 1968 football again i
formation tight end two receivers over
60 of the game nobody does that in
football or it's around 60 of the game
but
mike they always run the run play they
want to run into the look they want to
run so there's never wasted plays there
and then the execution
is absolutely top notch so between that
and they have a great offensive line you
know that was special and i felt like
there was a little bit too mike and this
is where new england's genius and some
of these runs
you know the guys that ended up having
to be in the really tough spot
were the two rookie middle linebackers
patrick queen malik harrison you know
it's just new england hey we coach them
well and hey i don't think these rookie
linebackers have really seen this type
of run scheme do they know how to defend
it and do that hey rookie defensive
tackle
matu baki i can't say his name from
texas a m excuse me
they they exposed him a little too but
it's just a great running attack uh by
that patriots offense
you know before we get too carried away
about where the patriots may go from
here given that they have won two in a
row and they're playing as well as they
have all season long yeah i was taking a
look at the standings they're still the
10th seed i know they got a lot of work
to do and not a long time to do it to
jump three teams they've got to jump
three teams to get themselves into
the uh the playoff mix and then again if
you're the chiefs the steelers
the ravens yeah anybody that plans to
play a home game in the postseason the
bills or the dolphins whoever wins that
division
you do not want
bill belichick
and company in a single elimination
setting you just don't and i don't care
that they're not as talented this year
as they are in past years that all goes
out the window when it's time to go to
the single elimination round and you're
going against the guy who has mastered
the single elimination round over the
last 20 years no thank you give me the
browns give me the raiders give me
anybody
but
bill belichick and the patriots yeah
that's scary they are you know i mean
first off i mean again let's not forget
we saw them go to toe to toe with the
chiefs without cam newton and really get
screwed over by probably the worst call
by a referee we saw all year where
they're gonna have a walk-in touchdown
on a fumble by patrick mahomes and they
called them into the grasp i mean that
was a huge moment in that game but
you're right mike they're scary they
have some elite things about their
football team their coaches elite
and their secondary's elite and their
offensive lines elite so when you have
three things like that you know right
match up
one game a limit that's scary that
really is and hey their coaching has
been flawless over the last few weeks i
know they lost to the bills
they played and managed that game
perfect other than the fumble at the end
cam newton has played perfect for three
weeks in a row other than that fumble
he's got a lot of pressure on him it's
not easy to play the way he's playing
they ran the ball they ran screens they
ran a few play action passes his ability
to run the ball gives them a great
advantage with their other run attack
because you do have to worry about the
element of him keeping the ball and then
between that
and then mike i i this here's my last
thing just like
they score touchdowns still tom brady's
not there but there's the great
baltimore ravens defense and they get
down in the red zone and they score
three freaking touchdowns and that's
because coaching and what they do and uh
i just can't give you know belichick and
mcdaniels enough credit in that category
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports